en circuit à respecter un temps plutôt
frisquet mais la magie de noël atténuent
chaud aux visiteurs à rambouillet on
trouve ça bien là tout un circuit qui
est mis en place donc on sait en
sécurité et puis bah ça nous permet de
sortir de faire des achats
ça donne aussi des idées bien sûr et
puis on fait un dépôt de nos achats
c'est agréable d'être dehors de prendre
l'air et de voir des belles choses quand
même 35 exposants ont répondu présent à
l'appel de la bergerie nationale des
artisans principalement locaux qui
attendent souvent beaucoup des marchés
de noël pour moi l'an dernier et a
représenté 70 % de mon chiffre
d'affaires annuel je réalise des bijoux
en verre que je travaille au chalumeau
et ils sont montés donc soit sur racine
oxydable soit sur argent au sur a et c
sont que des pièces uniques puisque
jamais parce que il y avait eu beaucoup
de marchés qui ont été annulés et ça
fait plaisir aux visiteurs et aux
producteurs
c'est la période où on vend la bière de
noël et c'est également les activités
des ventes directes et les marchés avec
le 2ème confinement de nombreuses
animations dû être annulés ces marchés
de noël est vécue comme un soulagement
franchement ça nous fait vraiment du
bien le voilà les gens ont du sang du
patient t on était ouvert pour les
scolaires du lundi au vendredi mais
fermé mercredi samedi dimanche depuis
les vacances de la toussaint on voit que
les gens ils ont à la fois envie d'aller
se promener sur la ferme d'aller à la
rencontre des animaux et se promener sur
le marché le marché de noël mais
effectivement les gens sont au rendez
vous et si les distances devait être
respecté entre les visiteurs il y en a
deux pour qui cette journée était plutôt
câline
[Musique]